mon propre rôle qui paraît dans la
collection de poche folio en deux
volumes
ce sont les textes qu'à rédiger serge
gainsbourg entre 1958 et sa mort
l'ensemble dépassé 600 pages le bougre
avait un tel talent que l'on lit avec un
agrément réel ses paroles sans musique
qui prennent de la sorte un nouveau
relief
en voici trois exemples leurs amis
raucoules le moineau pepy caquette la
poule
jackass l'api le chameau blatter et le
hibou eu ras le la panthère et crac
la grue toi sois belle et tais toi c'est
la saison des pluies la fin des amours
assis sous la véranda ce regard de
pleurer sept enfants peu et antennes et
j'ai mis au propre mes idées sales ou
propres et au figuré mon écriture
horizontale avec les plaintes aînés
délié gaz brossy était un inventeur de
mots extrêmement doué apocalypse tite la
légion étrange les plaisirs triste plus
que de rimbaud cette approche de
verlaine et de prêts verts